in our series vaccinating america
three doctors document their experiences
getting a coveted vaccine
to give us an in-depth look at what it
was like and the symptoms they felt
dr erica harris dr gabe baslet and dr
charles thompson recorded video diaries
over a period
of three to six days
i'm documenting my experience because i
want to share with everyone so follow
along with me
today is my vaccine day and i'm very
excited
i'm actually in front of my christmas
tree because the vaccine is
really the only wish i had for christmas
this year i am in the parking lot
getting ready to go in
hey buddy i've seen a lot of tears today
too all done that was it
no reactions i feel fine all right
i barely felt that it felt just like
getting my flu shot it did not hurt
uh any more so than a flu vaccine it's
been about nine hours since i had my
vaccine this morning i'm feeling pretty
well overall
not having any fevers fatigue weakness
anything out of the ordinary
i have a little bit of soreness in the
arm i got my shot about
13 hours ago um i sup well
i got a little soreness i feel fine i
received the vaccine yesterday
my arm is less sore than it was uh
yesterday evening i'm not feeling any
reactions i'm not having any real
symptoms no lightheadedness
it's been 24 hours since uh
my vaccination and i gotta be honest i
was tired today
uh i felt really fatigued i kind of had
a headache at the end of the day and
that's not normal for me
this is day two after getting my covert
vaccine i'm feeling really
great chip diagnostics successful
awaiting instructional commands
just kidding i'm about 40 hours past my
immunization
and uh feeling pretty good
the fatigue and headache that i had
yesterday is gone i feel totally back to
normal
i really hope that this has helped
demystify things a little bit for people
i
am hoping that this can be a solution
for us to help eradicate this pandemic
we waited so long to get some kind of
hope in the middle of this pandemic and
for us this is really our first sign of
hope we have more cases and deaths
every day now than we ever have but i
think the vaccine gives me hope
that slowly slowly over the course of
this next
six months to a year things will get
better